[Music]
hola gente good morning everyone today
is a very special day because it is my
official
six week postpartum visit so i'm gonna
be going to see my midwife and
luca and casey are coming with me too
right now look at luca he's being a good
boy his little rocker oh my gosh she's
so freaking cute i just want to eat him
up with kisses so right now casey and i
good morning good morning we are making
breakfast we are gonna eat really quick
and then we're gonna head out to the
appointment i don't know i'm really
looking forward to this appointment
because the six week mark is like
you know like that's that's the starting
point of like being normal again pretty
much
and so like this whole entire time these
past six weeks my midwife told me like
don't cook don't vacuum don't do laundry
like don't lift a finger just be let the
husband do it all yeah like just be a
queen in bed with your baby so so
looking forward to tiff helping me out
with cooking yeah and all this stuff but
hold on you've been doing that yet i
have been doing things and that's why
she had to tell me to stop doing things
because i was literally like driving
isaac to his basketball practice
um i was cooking i cooked a few times
and i've definitely been doing all the
laundry doing all the laundry um so
i haven't been just laying in bed and
being on queen status so that's why she
was telling me like hey you need to take
it easy
and like rest like these first six weeks
are really important and you just need
to really
rest and let your body heal and yeah i
really needed to take a step back
because i was like feeling myself like
my stitches and stuff sometimes like
they would be irritating a little bit so
i'm like oh yeah i think i'm doing too
much i gotta chill so for these past
couple weeks i've really taken like a
step back and not driven or not done
anything i shouldn't be doing i mean
like i said i'm still doing the laundry
but yeah like i don't know just casey's
been wonderful he's been like taking
over all the cooking and doing all that
stuff so every morning he's been making
me breakfast but this morning here
it's the six week mark i'm like hey i
get to be down here too and i get to
help i'm gonna make up no more done
making your own
yeah the oatmeal i just said i would
make a milkshake for us not true
so much for the help
and it's also been really hard actually
to just do anything because luca is just
so attached like any time we try to put
him down like he'll just be like
and then he'll start crying so that's
why right now with this rocker thing
it's vibrating
and i had to like keep my hand on his
chest for a while before he like started
crying and like freaking out and luckily
he stayed but it's just it's been a
challenge like even put him down
[Music]
and after breakfast every single day i
take my vitamins
and the vitamins that i take are ritual
which by the way thank you ritual for
sponsoring today's video i've been using
ritual throughout my entire pregnancy
and even before my pregnancy because
they say when you're trying to get
pregnant it's really good to take
prenatal vitamins to like prepare your
body with all the right nutrients and
i've been taking ritual for a really
long time now i can't even tell you
exactly how long and the reason why i
decided to take rituals because i knew
exactly what i was putting in my body
because unlike other brands rituals
products are made traceable and what
that means is from their sourcing to
their testing to the packaging ritual
makes it very clear to tell you where
their ingredients are coming from and
why they're there so because of that
reason i felt much more confident to
take rituals prenatal every single day
so as you can see i'm almost done with
my ritual
prenatal multivitamins i'm about to
finish this bottle but i'm about to
start my essential postnatal
multivitamin i'm really excited to take
the postnatal vitamins because ritual
knows how to support a person's body
especially after they've given birth in
fact the postpartum period is way more
nutritionally demanding so for example
breastfeeding increases the body's
demand for nutrients so rituals
postnatal supplement actually contains
15 nutrients compared to prenatals 12.
so
it definitely got my body covered every
morning i've also been taking rituals
essential protein shake and i love
adding that to my breakfast milkshake oh
my god it's so delicious you guys like
it tastes so good and it smells really
good too and i love the fact that it's
vegan and it's naturally sweetened with
fermented sugar and monk fruit it tastes
so good and it just makes me feel really
good that i'm giving my body all those
extra nutrients that it needs because i
am exclusively breastfeeding and the
cool thing is you can take this protein
shake during your pregnancy too so it's
for prenatal and postnatal so i honestly
recommend ritual during pregnancy and
after and you can get yourself ritual as
well if you go to ritual.com tiffcase20
you will get 20 off your first month or
you can just use the code tiffcase20a at
checkout and you'll get your discounts
remember
take your vitamins
all right so before heading out i've had
to breastfeed one more time and when i
watch
luca drink milk it makes me
wonder how good it tastes because he
makes it
sounds so good he makes the cutest sound
he does and it just he makes it look so
good i'm like what are you enjoying
there like i want to try some so would
you mind if i tried some of your
booby milk i'm actually surprised it
took you six weeks to ask i for sure
thought you would you would have asked a
long time ago actually the first time
you breastfed luca
i did think to myself i want to try the
breast milk but because he was so like
he's a preemie he was so frail and so
little
single ounce yeah i was like i feel i
would feel bad like hey give me a little
drop of that you know like
he needed it that's true especially the
early milk like the colostrum that's
like liquid gold like that's like the
most nutritious like the most beneficial
so i wouldn't have given you a drop of
that true and it's like super nutritious
for them like it's like his only food
source it's like the ultimate protein
shake right
yeah you're taking all the rituals and
everything too so it's like it's like
literally feeding right into your breast
milk and there are a lot of people like
i know bodybuilders buy breast milk
because it's so nutritious or whatever i
did try my breast milk with isaac when i
was pregnant with eyes or when i had
isaac but it was just like a tiny little
like yeah kind of thing like i didn't
drink it
so i don't know i guess i could
i could say i haven't really tried it it
was just like a little taste kind of
thing
i just remember it being really sweet
comparing it to like cantaloupe milk or
something like it's sweet i would not
have yet guessed that i thought it would
be like um like i've never tried goat
milk but like goat's milk but i i would
assume goat's milk is very gamey you
know like animal flavor i guess that's
my that's my guess and i figured breast
milk would be kind of in the same region
of like gaminess now you're saying it's
sweet so i really really do want to try
it yeah well right now i just fed luca
right before we go to the appointment
but i was actually thinking about
possibly pumping just in case we take a
little too long because it's pretty far
away
so i could pump some milk well i'm gonna
pump for him
and i can pop a little bit for us to
taste because i want to taste it too
actually i'm curious like i'm curious
and i want to taste it even though i've
already tasted it once before but like
again like actually like take a gulp
but i'm also kind of freaked out about
it why because it because you produced
it i produced it yeah not just that but
like it's like canon ballistic yeah it's
just weird does that mean he's cannon
ballistic
yeah but i'm doing it to myself like
right with me like my thing like i'm his
mom like that makes sense you should be
drinking mother's milk but
me drinking my own milk like i don't
know it kind of freaks me out a little
bit but i still like i don't want to
taste it my curiosity gets the best of
me i guess i mean to think that way it's
like if you think about it it's like we
we drink our own spit
[Music]
you know but it's like it's not gross to
us it's literally producing our own
mouths and we swallow it right back down
our own throats but if you think about
it that's pretty gross we drink so much
spit every single day so funny
does he look more yellow to you
a little bit
he's turning asian
you're talking about jaundice all right
okay so we'll try it sounds good all
right i just finished pumping i got
another bottle ready for luca for our
outing but here i have two ounces that
are just pumped or actually a little bit
more than two ounces that i had left
over
that we can try
[Music]
i just pumped this this just came out of
my body
this is just warmth there's a smell but
i can't pinpoint it now when i heat up
breast milk and
to feed bottle feed like there's this
there's definitely like a
a smell
smells like milk not like calories this
doesn't have a smell yeah it doesn't
smell i'm gonna have to reheat it though
there's a smell
i don't know why but i want a gag
really i wanna thinking about drinking
this but i still wanna do it like i just
wanna just do it and just get it over
with
i have to say
your throne here
is awesome yeah like your pregnancy
pillow thingy
this is i can see why you you sit here
majority of the day this is awesome i
wouldn't leave here either yeah that's
how i got to heal how do i trade with
you at night you can you can push him
out of your vagina and then we can trade
okay okay i'm gonna try it
drink my milk mama
it's a good stuff look alright look how
cute he looks
oh my baby
why are you so cute
i can't see him i'm talking to you he's
too close kidding
i know he looks cuter when you hold him
because when i hold him i can't see him
they're too close yeah that's why i'm
always like major double chin when i'm
looking at him yeah yeah
even if you tried you can't really do a
double chain your jaw is just so
mad like it's just so sharp okay
i am totally procrastinating
you first hit me first
uh i'm gonna go first i'll go first
i just want to get it over with and plus
i'm like it's the freshest
okay and then like i made it true
chicken dips
all right
this feels like a like a challenge
what what if you thought about it being
someone else's milk oh that's even worse
oh is it okay i don't know that's gross
i just came out of my body why is it
such a big deal just drink it
you saw your face through the viewfinder
that cracked me up
like we're just gonna do it and i was
like all right she's doing it and it
took so long
because i also didn't want to spill but
i'm also very like procrastinating but
then i saw your eyes going like
crack me up
okay
okay okay okay
okay
okay
okay
[Music]
like it was a really big big chunk was
it it took
milk it wasn't like a tiny little sip
it's actually really good is it good oh
no i'm gagging well you just said it was
good good but then i thought about the
fact that it came out of my body and
maybe gag
okay chill it tastes good but it tastes
not as sweet as i remember it with isaac
at least like the little dab that i
tasted it's also kind of like it tastes
like nothing at the same time
what if it's sweet nothing
it tastes like sweet nothing to me
i don't know how to describe
it
yeah
[Music]
that was a big cult
[Music]
it does taste it's like diet milk
what you're drinking
you're gonna just steal it all from your
son just kidding go ahead you want some
nothing's already full
this is good
this is it's actually sweeter it's
sweeter than regular milk yeah but to me
like in my mouth cow's milk i mean it
was like slightly sweet but mainly like
watery like nothing not even water
because water has a flavor but like
nothing i don't know how to describe it
maybe because it's my own oh maybe like
you can't smell your own bo the way yeah
other people's videos
okay you're going for thirds
oh you're not even drinking a lot it
looks like a little bit oh should i go
for a big one i don't know it's up to
you i like literally it sat in my mouth
for a while
before i swallowed so i was like trying
to really get a flavor out of it it's
good it's really it's better than cow's
milk i would compare it closer to almond
milk than cow's milk but you know what
this
reminds me that it makes me think about
it makes me think about why we have
sweet tooths yeah and humankind we're
programmed to like sweet things because
if this is the only thing we eat
for the first what like six months six
months of our lives and nothing else we
are
wired to like
sweet it doesn't want to make you gag
thinking it came out of your wife
no
i've con i've
tasted other things that came out of
your body
that's a good one
oh my god all right well we did it we i
tried it you tried it are you gonna want
to steal the rest of his mouth no
no do you want to finish this
save bro
you don't want it no it's okay i'll chug
it just kidding
you're like what what oh yeah i want to
do that you're funny alright we really
should head out now to the appointment
[Music]
all right we just finished at the
midwife
and uh
oh yeah we're still here yeah we uh
finished feeding
luka just now he's a happy camper now
and we weighed him and he weighs eight
pounds four ounces
which is mind-blowing the midwife was
like three pounds in six weeks this is
crazy like most babies gain like a pound
and a half in six weeks but luca here
he's gained a lot more than that and
look at these cheeks i can't see you
there's no one in here anyway so baby's
good i'm good i've been cleared for
physical exercise or what is it physical
movement so i can
work out now and do other things
and she was also checking if i had a
diastasis which is when the muscle and
your stomach like separate to make room
for a baby mine is completely closed
actually about
two weeks after he was born um i had
this service done where they they were
binding my stomach this like indonesian
technique they were binding but before
that they checked um to see if i had
like separation and it was like less
than one so that means like i barely
like my muscle barely open and that's
like really rare they're absolute steel
yeah like most women like they'll have
like a lot of separation the fact that i
look like i'm able to fit in my jeans
and like let me see
this is crazy like how did i lose my
belly completely like so when i had
isaac i thought i bounced back really
fast because i was 18. so i'm like oh
man i'm a teenager it's fine like you
know i'm meant to be
nice and tight really fast like my body
just snapped back but the fact that this
is happening at 32 and i don't have
anything i'm shocked i'm like whoa maybe
we'll try some exercise later tonight
and see what else bounce back okay
[Music]
all right after this six week postpartum
appointment now we are headed
to
sushi and not just any sushi
sugar fish and if you know anything
about us you know that we are constantly
raving at how amazing fish is honestly
the sushi is so good that puts japan
sushi to the test for sure at least for
my taste buds anyway i'm so excited i
haven't had sushi since before i was
pregnant
or at least raw sushi because we did
have that cooked sushi around
thanksgiving time or i guess it's not
really sushi yeah just cooked fish yeah
you've had sushi since i've been
pregnant yeah i was i was i went into
this with solid like solidarity in mind
like we're gonna do this together but
i had a few cheat meals for sure sorry
you've gotten to enjoy it no it's fine
but i haven't so i am so excited like so
excited and the fact that
we've waited six weeks for me to eat
sushi it's kind of ridiculous usually
sushi's like the first meal that a
postpartum mommy has
like right after having their baby but
yeah i don't know i've just been so
engulfed with having luca and being at
home i don't know it's just it just
feels comfortable to not leave and i
don't want to have delivered sushi so
that i was really adamant about that
because casey's like oh what if we just
have sushi delivered i'm like no no no
if i'm gonna eat sushi it has to be at
the restaurant it has to be fresh are
you gonna be a good boy would mommy and
daddy eat yeah you will look at you nice
and comfy
[Music]
this is our first time vlogging with a
stroller you look like such a mom now a
beautiful mom a beautiful mom
welcome to
earth downtown l.a baby
[Music]
how is that that's gotta be so
satisfying
[Music]
this